laughs or iPhone moving out there oh it
looks like a swimming pool from here ooh
I don't know if there's water makes you
a little stressed say the least
when we started this walk across Grand
Canyon from 500 miles to the east of
here
a friend told us we learn the difference
between what we want and what we need as
Kevin and I marched into western Grand
Canyon the step back we passed through
speaker passageway into what some
describe the gods food
a place very few visit day 45 are
walking no precipitation in sight even
though it's mid-february and we are back
in full desert
[Music]
Western Grand Canyon is incredibly
remote and Ament and then some and water
is extremely scarce that scarcity
reminded us daily at the park and all
the development projects surrounding its
landscape share this major often
overlooked obstacle limited water
finding water when you're far from the
river sometimes 3000 feet above it isn't
easy to read upended on very thin very
unpredictable potholes of rain water
pretty nice to syringes that's like a
swimming pool just don't fall in there
because there's no bottom in that thing
act that I can see for here
they were the key to our survival water
challenge day by day thing
inter-confessional thank you
constantly amazed by the liquid silence
seems to blanket ass down here
is there any water no you're right
you will clean her underwear without
them up I'm right now it's just huge
okay hi yourself no get the hell out of
me after hiking some 12 to 15 miles a
day for over a month
[Music]
some days hiking over 20 miles to reach
water let's just say the Boris down
let's hope with your feet ain't really
hurt somebody's falling apart like I'm
nice we sauna okay 58 day on the trail
whatever it may have been the brushy ax
scratchiest longest day Wow a time Lulu
Kevin might have even become the cat
grouchy climb obi-wan kenobe style to
get to Wilderness hoo-ha and my [ __ ]
that that look where we've come from
yeah look where he comes from [ __ ]
nowhere encounters with cactus didn't
help
what you selling to the broker and I
gotta lose weight lumps yeah okay let's
put him away
fish Oh shake her I can fight literally
made my cap on them
woohoo I got you I got your physical
challenges aside careful
we discovered a solitude and stillness
that was experienced nowhere else as we
approach the end of the park and our
walk we discovered and heard the
different Grand Canyon
a tourist room has followed the success
of the reason skywalk development on the
Hualapai reservation on the southwest
corner of the park over a decade ago the
FAA granted approval to fly and land
helicopters below the rim what is now
called helicopter alley located on the
border of the national park it is now
one of the business heliport in the
world and way of industrialized
high-volume
tourism coming to the National Park the
acceleration of this kind of activity
has been incredible economic Enterprise
of these tribal nations is important for
them you know they basically starved for
100 years now they have something
[Music]
the helicopters are a mess you know
there's there's this constant air
traffic and it affects the wildlife you
know we're a hunting tried propagate
forward 15 years the dreams capture and
we've really done what we set out to do
with Teddy Roosevelt set out to do in
you know letting mainly the rest of the
world come fly over Grand Canyon
National Park and in you know negate the
laws that we created to protect these
places when we started this cloth we
have no idea what we've gotten into nor
how far under kitchen would be our
sixty-day over 650 mile hiking immersion
is not about being on a list who's about
understanding a shared resource found
jewel of our National Park System well
it was a journey to find a line to one
of the seven natural wonders of the
world which means
man
result requests understand what might
change or be lost image rocket fuel
we don't find a balance in growing
development pressures
resource extraction and the sublime
beauty that define this iconic landscape
and how we decide to use and experience
our last wild places will dictate what
the future of this place looks like
[Music]
you